hey youtubers is Charlie since it's been
a long time since I've done an anime
video and I just found out that I have
like a free crunchyroll Guest Pass to
give out I thought I'd do a fun giveaway
and talk about my top 5 crunchyroll
anime that are airing right now most of
the time I use crunchyroll for streaming
old anime that I missed you know like
really important stuff that my friends
recommend to me but that for some reason
I just never got around to but the
really cool thing is is that crunchyroll
simulcast stuff when it airs in Japan so
whenever a new series comes like attack
on Titan season 2 for instance you'll be
able to watch it within an hour of
people in Japan watching it usually
everyone else has to wait like six
months for someone else to pick it up so
seriously if you don't have crunchyroll
right now get on that I'll explain the
giveaway at the end of the video but
right now here's my top 5 Prince your
all anime starting with number 5
parasite schedule
this isn't exactly for the faint of
heart this is a slightly more mature
anime parasites come take over the earth
the one that tries to inhabit the body
the protagonist isn't able to enter his
brain so they both retain separate
personalities eventually they start
working together to battle the other
parasites number four flowers of evil
so though communication Luxio
Anna Mikado soo ah kun Ohana sagat's
itsuka also ties this is also slightly
darker in the animation style with a
slightly odd character design just makes
it a little bit creepier which i think
is really awesome
this boy falls in love with a girl at
school that he's inspired by steals her
gym uniform one day another student sees
him and then starts to blackmail him
like in this really weird deviant
storyline it's a lot of fun if you like
school based anime that they take really
dark twists sometimes people the real
monsters as we've actually is we've
learned from attack on Titan on to
number three law horizon
this is the story of a bunch of online
gamers that get sucked into a game
fairly simple premise it's one of the
more fun titles on my list it doesn't
take itself too seriously not as
seriously as some of the darker anime
and it's not just about the big battles
they have inside this game world it does
take a little bit to get going but it
doesn't lay too heavily on the romance
subplot so if you really don't like
shipping and stuff like that it doesn't
get too heavy into that stuff on to
number 2 fate/zero
no yonas tales end anymore
wanna see Hotaru koko de Yukito Ava here
you don't how much you yawn tear stop
story no go does it
Sarris I know a lot of people think that
season 2 of this is better than season 1
crunchyroll has both so it's not like
you have to pick but it's like a prequel
series for fate/stay night in the
timeline it takes place about 10 years
prior to the events of that series along
with my number one pick this is one of
the more epic series so if you like
really big sweeping fantasy epic series
this is a really good title to watch and
my number one pick no surprise here
attack on titan salad okey my desktop
sada kono sekai
and everyone wants to know what season 2
is going to come out and there been a
lot of rumors about the manga getting
spoiled so the creator had like redo the
ending the original ending to attack on
Titan the final ending the studio that's
making this just got held up a little
bit so season 2 will get here eventually
and the thing you should really get
excited about is that crunchyroll
simulcasted so like when I was watching
this during season 1 I was watching it
as it was airing in Japan everybody that
was using other services had to wait
like 6 months to watch it and for those
that are really into the manga
crunchyroll also has access for premium
users to all the manga for free and the
same is true for the rest of their make
a library here's my big question for you
guys like in the last six months or so
what has been your favorite crunchyroll
anime series honestly I think the thing
I like most about crunchyroll is that I
can just I can watch it on all of my
devices which you can't do with a lot of
other services the simulcast thing is
definitely a big strike in its favor too
but here's the details on my giveaway so
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video real simple it's just a Guest Pass
so you do have to have a crunchyroll
profile so that I can I can give you the
Guest Pass it's basically like a free
premium subscription if you guys have no
idea what I'm talking about you never
heard a crunchyroll before I'll have
some links in the description straight
to the website that'll explain like what
the different tiers of subscription are
there is a free service so you can watch
it for free but you don't get to
simulcast and you don't get HD really
it's only like seven dollars for like
the basic subscription so you get HD get
like all the good stuff and you get
access to all the manga so I would just
recommend that I know I haven't done any
anime series in a while
I'm hoping this summer I'll have a
little bit more time so I can actually I
pick something but if you haven't seen
it a long time ago I did something
called anime club you can actually click
here to check those out it was a lot of
fun I'm kind of bummed that I got a
little too busy to keep doing it but
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight